welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Ali Sowinski a
professor of economics and the
co-director of the macroeconomic
research program at the Cowell's
foundation at yale university professor
Sowinski is here to talk with us about
his new research on Russian values and
their attitudes toward the west welcome
professor Sowinski well it's better to
be here so in a nutshell your research
has shown Russians have negative values
towards the west give us the highlights
of your findings so our research shows
that Russians do not like the West they
do not like the democracy they do not
like the free markets they do not like
the Western economic and social model
for their society at the same time which
is paradoxically the very very poor
capitalist in the real life they're uber
capitalists in the way they conduct
their daily business and the way they
behave so that's one big fine novella
research the second big find is that the
attitudes of Russians the values of
Russians changed over time so they
became much more against the West much
more against the Western economic and
social model in their attitudes and
there are very interesting vacations for
wide wireless cell so this differs from
20 years ago when Russians were pretty
pro West why the change actually the 20
year ago the first research on the
values of rush the first serious
research in the valence of Russian was
conducted by my colleague Bob Shiller
here at Yale his co-authors from Russia
so they have conducted a series of four
interviews where they talked to people
in Moscow and thurs work and some
Ukrainian cities and they asked about
their values towards the west and just
in general about their valises the first
serious research on the values of
reference so they showed that there is
no such thing as homeless of Atticus
there is no such thing as Soviet man and
in the beginning of the 90s the edge of
the Russians was very much
for was very much similar to the ones
that person Europe or a person in the US
would have now the situation has
drastically changed we see that in the
surveys conducted in 2008 Russians are
very negative towards the west and
moreover this attitude becomes worse and
worse and worse even compared to say
2004 so we have seen a drastic reversals
of the values of the attitudes that
Russians have let's talk about your
methodology how did you gather the data
so they did we have is actually are
quite interesting because I pull up set
posing to the different from the usual
surveys at having a one or two thousand
members who are asked about their values
who are asked about their attitudes have
a very very large data set we have about
forty thirty four thousand people who
are asked about all these questions and
the survey is conducted by very large
Russian polling organization that does
political polling it's called the public
opinion foundation so it's 64 regions
rural urban people of all social
backgrounds etc etc so it's very very
detailed data not only asking about the
values but also about all kinds of
social and economic characteristics of
people so in some sense we can zoom in
into the mind of an average Russian and
see what they're thinking about so
moreover this this foundation is very
motivated very well funded very
motivated it does political politics one
of the biggest political pollsters in
Russia so we have spectacular data set
and moreover the data set that spans
from two thousand three to two thousand
eight so for example compared to the
telephone surveys we have much more
detailed and much more comprehensive
data what did you find most surprising
when you analyze the data so one thing
they actually shocked me was that the
attitudes the negative attitudes towards
the west are the highest among the
oldest generation and also the youngest
generation and people who are the most
positive towards the west are the people
between age 35 and 45 so one could say
well how could this be
the guys were born you know who are 35
to 45 now the boring Soviet Union they
were probably brainwashed by the Soviet
propaganda which portrayed West has been
evil negative militarist etc so why are
there is so much more positive than say
the younger generation who grew up with
McDonald's western movies all kinds of
TV shows MTV and the explanation we have
is as follows so people who are 35 to 45
they have seen the negative part of the
Soviet Soviet Society the absence
complete absence of freedom Russian you
know food very low consumption or low
diversity of consumption so they know
what it is to live in the Soviet Union
the younger generation I romanticize the
Soviet Union so they don't see the
negative parts of it but the only I know
they only see the positive parts of it
so so they're as negative as the very
old generation who lost from the from
the fall of the Soviet Union so it's the
first surprising part the second
surprising part is how drastically the
values of Russian change the negative
attitudes of the Russians changed in
this 20 years we talked a little bit
about that already and the explanation I
think is is very interesting for this so
think about the 90s in the 90s there
were all kinds of liberal economic
reforms democratization the society
moved from a very rigid soviet socialist
society to essentially the free market
to the wild west-style free market at
the same time the people experienced
very difficult economic times the gdp
fell the consumption fell then and 2000
coincided the the oil prices one top and
also here are some other economic
reports by then but at the same time the
democratization the liberal economic
reforms were pulled back so an average
Russian is thinking the fall of an you
know in the 90s the were there was free
market but we live very badly in two
thousand to two thousand eight the
country experienced spectacular gross at
seven percent per year for ten years so
well it must be the case that democracy
and the free markets are bad and the
strong government
the pull back of the liberal reform the
State Corporation etc are good so so we
see this the economy affecting the
beliefs and the values of the Russians
and what is interesting also that Russia
actually not the only country that has a
similar phenomenon so French economist
at goosetown line the air and they with
the smart documented something similar
for France as well so in France in the
post-war period the post-second World
War period the economy grew very well
and it coincided with a larger
involvement of the government in the
economy and you can still see that
French think that say compared to the US
or compared to Britain that if the
government involvement in the economy is
much better so we see that this
correlation between economic growth
feeding into the values of both Russians
and French and for Russians it's much
more drastic so what is important to
look at these values and beliefs so the
key question for Russia is how to
reconcile the dislike for the democracy
and they dislike for economic reforms
that an average Russian has with the the
absolute need to push for such reforms
so Roger is actually pretty rich country
now so in purchasing power parity it's
about thirteen thousand dollars dollars
gdp per capita somewhere between
children or iguana so all the
low-hanging fruits of economic reforms
have been already picked so now to
really grow and this is a very important
question for the society how to grow
fast the the new way new economy has to
be built there has to be more
innovations it has to be more
democratization but on the other hand
the values of Russians pose a threat to
that so how could so if Russia is
democratic than the voters the media and
Russian would say no we don't want the
liberal air force we don't want more
market freedom so in one hand it can be
that either the Russian can be
non-democratic but grow fast according
to the values of Russians or to be
democratic but pull back the economic
reforms so in other words the values of
Russians pose a constraint on economic
growth
just as much as the institutions or
technology fascinating and do you think
policymakers in the United States can
use this research somehow yeah it's very
important to for our for the US
policymakers to understand what's going
with the values of Russians so everybody
thought at least in the beginning of the
ninth is that as Russia will become a
richer more affluent society that the
attitudes towards the west are gonna be
much more positive so in fact Russia has
indeed achieved the level of prosperity
unheard of or unseen in the whole
Russian history so just an average
Russian and listener Russians in big
cities you can travel abroad you know go
to sushi restaurants see western movies
at the same time they have very negative
attitudes towards the west so in fact
much worse attitudes then were at the
beginning of the democratization the
collapse of the Soviet Union so if one
hopes that if Russia becomes even more
prosperous that it will become more
positive towards the west I think it's a
dangerous question so it one has to
think about this as well so the second a
point that comes from our research is
that if one wants to influence how
Russians view the West one has to really
think about what parts of the society
support the Western what what parts
don't so for example you know the the
core constituents is supporting the West
is actually the people 35 to 45 year
olds but the younger generation is lost
in some sense for the positive failures
to the vestment they already are as bad
as the 60 year olds who grow up in the
Soviet Union who lost essentially
everything or many many things with with
the democratization so I think it's very
important to target the younger group
and target their attitudes towards the
west and also to understand that the
core support is actually 35 to 45 year
olds very interesting well thank you
very much for being here today and
sharing your research with us well thank
you for more information about professor
sowinski and his research please visit
our website at
I led you back / Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you